Heba abdul razzaq comes from Egypt she's
worked in many countries now she's doing
two years of research in molecular
medicine at the University of Cologne
here in in Cologne and in this lab
especially they are among the best not
only not only in Europe but also in
Germany they produce very high quality
of viruses that I am able to transfer to
my stem cells with high purity and
without any toxic ation to the cells
abdul razzaq is part of an international
team who's working language is English
she's learning hardly any German here
yes and this is another kind of tube
because it has a conical and it can
spend a normal out today 40 so much what
they are putting it on the right the
University of Cologne provides extra
personal support for foreign students
language barriers and the unfamiliar
customs often keep them from feeling
comfortable in Germany only a few
universities organize such programs
although integration is important for
research vehicles and for toilet inter
that's one of the great advantages of
internationalization is the variety of
viewpoints that enter into the research
there's a good reason why all successful
research institutes like those at
cologne University take a strongly
international approach stock internets
are not Oscar festival international
exchange works though not always outside
the university
abdul razzaq for example has a hard time
getting used to the reserved manner
Germans often display she looks for
places that give her a feeling of being
back home she already knows one day
she'll be returning to Egypt a lot of
reasons not only and not only one reason
in the main issue is is that I want to
be back with a family especially with
the situations in Egypt now plus I'm not
that happy also living alone I'm you
thinking so it's not I'm not that happy
living alone I'm not very much
integrated into German culture I feel in
the University that I'm I'm foreigner
like Heba abdul razzaq one in every ten
scientists in Germany has a foreign
passport and much like her many of them
take their highly qualified knowledge
back home with them after a few years